i know you guys got to um reunite
after not having seen each other for a
few months i know tia told us it was
really
tearful what was it like for you getting
to see her and hug her and just
you know be with her again it was
amazing i loved it family
is huge to me
um and not only that it was great to
have everyone together
the kids uh my kids hadn't seen
her kids in about a year and i think
what sometimes you know
maybe people don't understand is we
actually live in two different places
yeah
so i live in northern california she
lives in southern california
and ev whenever we wanted to come down
and bring the kids there was always an
influx of of more like coveted cases
right they had increased in l.a los
angeles
took a little bit longer than other
places to
get it together um so she was always she
is very
cold like she is you you have to come
correct
even if you got a test you'd have to
take a test at her house you should be
very very strict about that and as as
she should
um so we weren't able to to get everyone
together
until the time that we did and i had
seen her prior maybe like
two three uh it was probably two months
she had a shield on she had a mask it
was kind of like outside
but we couldn't really like hug and like
hang
we were two sisters
moms um family members together
just doing people may think it's corny
but
if you know what family you know truly
means yeah we
crafted together we got the kids
together we
were doing crafts we watched a disney
movie
uh we drank wine
yeah we keyed a little bit
it was perfect it was like uh
you know like where we left off i love
it
[Applause]
um well first of all we did a little
thing in our goodbyes yesterday
like because it showed your rehearsal
and i had no clue
that you were the seashell no clue
so when you're unmasked and you have
that moment what's that moment like
i can breathe
[Laughter]
uh i was i mean
if i'm honest i was a little sad when i
heard my
when i heard my character's name um
because i felt like i was just getting
started
i had just finally kind of like let
loose
my voice was getting a little bit uh
more clear
and what a lot of people don't know is
um i
actually had because of the seashell the
way it was
positioned if you saw in the beginning
my head was doing this
i had to balance it so i got a little uh
muscle uh spasm oh like a cricket unit
yeah
and it was affecting the way i was
singing so finally that was gone
because we had fixed the the head and
then it was like well seashell's going
away
but uh i immediately i'm the type of
person that always likes to turn
you know my lemons into lemonade and
i was like you know i'm gonna live my
80s
rock band kind of like dream um and
i did it was nice to take it off finally
reveal and be me hopefully
you know tamara mori housley and
not be afraid to sing um because in the
beginning yes
i was i was nervous but towards the end
i was like let's just have fun did adam
know
or and did your babies know or did you
just like
who knew because you know adam you have
to be
so secretive um and they ask you
who did you tell you're like
i just told the people who were kind of
like in my
small circle in that moment okay um
it was my husband obviously because he
had to take me to the airport
and you know i had to leave i'm not even
tia
not even my brother oh yeah
yeah behavior not even my children you
know
uh aiden and and and aria i
was going to tell them yeah and then uh
the producers like you know what no
we like not telling your siblings
um because it's always fun to see them
kind of like try and figure it out with
the rest of the world
yeah and that's what was happening they
were texting each other
and of course like once i performed i
mean there's there's there's no
there's no hiding it did your babies
once they watched did they know it was
you a meal
they didn't nope nope nope uh
i literally told my children
two days ago so i told my sister
and my brother before my children
that's hilarious i did
my daughter she was like mommy
that's you then literally this was the
next thing she said like
so serious where's the where where's the
costume
can i have it no did you get were you
able to get it for her
no no nobody could be a seashell again
girl i would have tried to take that
home
i know but i did part ways with her
because i'm the seashell kind of like to
me
represented that mask represented the
older version of tamara
i am a newer person now that i've been
i've done this and i remember seeing
that change in adrian
um and there's something that is so
magical about that show that
that does this it's because i truly feel
you face a fear so it was freeing and
nice
to have these people talk about seashell
in such a positive way
and them not know who you know i
i really was and i also learned too that
stereotypes can come with
someone's uh perception of who they
think you are
so then comes comments opinions
or whatever so it was really nice to
kind of just
go out there with a completely clean uh
slate and just have an amazing time
that's great that's really great there
were a lot of um references to sister
sister
in the hands that they that they were
giving so
i mean it i don't know if nicole just
tuned into that or she loved the show
and maybe that's what
that's what did it um for you guys you
guys are now on netflix the show is and
i have to tell you
my younger cousins are like now
discovering this
show that i thought i loved growing up
so how cool is that the new generation
is getting
to discover your show and what you and
tia did
it's pretty freaking crazy um so the way
i see it
is that sister sister has become a
classic
and what an amazing blessing to be able
to say that
you know show with people of color on it
yeah
uh and that's what was so great about
sister sister it broke
so many um barriers
in the sense of having these young black
women wear their natural hair
right have these um young
black women from people all over the
world
paris spain italy
love this show i've had so
many people come up to me and say i
learned english
from washington yeah how cool is that
that's amazing
i was a little bummed when you left the
real last year um i loved you i love the
group of you ladies on there
but i wonder are you done with hosting
or do you want to do more now are you
gonna do some music like
no i am not done with hoping
i'm actually doing home and family uh
it's on hold
cameron and debbie i said what's up
that's why i'm in my trailer right now
i think it i love it i think it comes
you know natural to me
um the reason why i love the schedule
that i have now is because i get the
best of both worlds yeah i have free
time
to host if i want to to act if i want to
um i made a four picture deal with
hallmark
um i have the capability of bringing
diversity um you know to that channel i
love
it i love christmas so it's the perfect
pairing
now i get to host um i'm hosting a
baking show on food network
hulu with billions he was the culinary
pastry chef for the obamas so i get to
have
i was on the math singer i was in the
sing so i have
all this free time to do the things that
i absolutely
love to do because i actually wear so
many hats and i love to kind of like put
my fingers
in um in everything but the most
important is i have that down time
to be with my babies
stuffed fully the coolest thing about
these projects are like three
weeks at a time so i can rest be with my
kids and then when i get that
work like kind of bug again my mom
i have a great supportive husband
who is literally he's like my number one
fan
and uh i i i i mean that not like oh dan
no like he is i'll say this he is my
cheerleader
[Music]